well first of all happy new year thank
you so much for having me before I start
up a quick confession I had no idea what
a big deal this class was till about
last week I just got back from the Rose
Bowl I was looking up my cat yeah go
stanford i was looking at my calendar
and I staff just talked with Tina Sealy
that's what I put talk with Tina city
like me and Tina 10 what so then she
calls me and we're going over the talk
and she says been to the website and I
see people like my rainpow jobs and the
Sequoia I next week and I would week
after week after week after week and I
said thank God I'm first I'm so thank
you so much for having I'm excited I
really want to structure this talk on in
like three dimensions so first one talk
about sort of the startup phase or
campaigning and some of the lessons
learned from there that may be helpful
in your entrepreneurial thought life um
secondly I want to talk about the scale
up a ramp up face which i would call
kind of the governing phase after
campaigning what does it mean to be an
elected official how do you govern how
you create policy and then I went to in
with some new challenges and new
horizons um so I started running for
office if someone would have told me my
freshman year at Stanford that I would
be a city council person in Stockton I
want to look at them and told them they
were crazy I had no intention of coming
back to Stockton I was conned upset
Stanford was so close to home I want to
be as far away from home as possible
it's not because home was a bad place or
a place I didn't love whether they're
not people i like is because home was
difficult and challenging but I realized
that Stanford out loud my passions came
from sort of the pains growing up in
poverty with a single parent in the car
serrated father may be really really
passionate about things like inequality
things like poverty things like mass
incarceration and I realized even before
I ran for office I sort of my pain
points were leading me to what I think
are thought my passion our purpose might
be then by junior year I was interning
in the White House through the Stanford
the government program and my job was
when the office of intergovernmental
affairs not supposed to work with mayors
and council members nationwide crazy
foreshadowing and I hated it
alright which is also kind of
foreshadowing I'm joking but I hated I
spent 12 hours a day googling what the
mayor of Laredo Texas was doing or
googling what Cory Booker was doing a
new worker would catch some Rida between
Atlanta and it was so so so boring but
opened my eyes to how people are making
big changes in a small really local
level that no one really knew I care
about so I remember talking to my boss
and saying you know what one day I'm
gonna support people in stock thinkin
Stockton's my hometown to my community
and to the place and need of good
governance so I thought I would be the
donor the Thunder and then someone else
could do the messy work of going to the
beatings and dealing with people who may
you may or may not like and then they're
on the same time on Halloween one of my
first cousins was murdered at a house
party in stockton and sadly in stockton
even today we made some strides but for
far too many young people especially
young men of color homicides or
premature death are almost a fact of
life but it was the first time we were
slower than my family so it hit me
really personally and i remember flying
back home for the funeral and dealing
with the pain and the anger and the
frustration like why did this happen i
remember having to console my aunt and
my mother and my cousin's it has squelch
beef and make sure people didn't
retaliate and i realized that all the
great time I was having at Stanford
whether it was interning at Google or
being in the white house or having
access to great speakers and electric
series like this had to be for much more
than my own personal fulfillment it had
to be so much bigger than me getting the
degrees and making a lot of money that
that for some reason that my part or the
stage which I suppose to play my life
meant that I would have to go back to
Stockton and run for office one day I'm
so I told my mom you know what mom one
day but when I'm 30 34 38 40 to 50 i'll
come back to stockton and help out
because it said you really needs help
but then my senior year I was applying
for fellowships and jobs and I didn't
get what I thought was mine I was an
entitled Stanford since I good grades I
had worked hard I had the best Rex are
the best resume I thought for sure that
was my job in my
purpose and life to be a Rhodes Scholar
and that's just what was going to happen
for me so I put all my eggs in that
basket and then didn't work out for me
um so there I remember being so upset so
hurt like I thought I found my purpose
this one supposed to be doing and though
I can't do it and I and I start with
that because it was on all these value
experiences all these low points whether
growing up in poverty or losing my
cousin are not getting the fellowship
that really clarified the path I was
going to take I'm sorry I gave a TED
talk I said for two years ago talking
about transforming Valley experiences
and to mountaintop ones and that's the
first point I want to start with today
is that if in these Valley experiences
these low points that gave me the
clarity I needed to figure out what it
was I was doing it was in the failures
and rejections in the pain that I
thought in purpose and it was in all
these low points i was able to
recalibrate refocus and figure out that
was my job to run for office and stop in
one day so februari 20th 2012 after a
sign language class I rushed down the
Stockton for my campaign kickoff I was
going to run for City Council in
stockton and the second lesson from the
campaign is the i did that expert advice
really isn't all that expert when i was
first running for office first of all
people said I was crazy which is partly
true they're like you're crazy Stockton
just had back-to-back years of record
homicides you're you're you're crazy
you're running against an incumbent
whose chair of his party you're crazy
because there's no way as the City of
Stockton is going to like a 20 to 21
year old at the time black kid from
south stockton to helping its resurgence
there's no way you're crazy and then
when I said is going to run anyway all
the experts that consultants the people
who make a lot of money to advise the
people who've been doing this for a long
time they said you know what tubs you're
young so I grow some facial hair I'm
trying you see they say you're young
grow some facial hair so you look a
little bit older or they said you're
young so stay away from young people and
youth issues don't speak to any of that
talk about growing up issues and then
they sent talk about the bankruptcy talk
about how the city is bankrupt and
finance
and that's what's going to resonate with
voters and luckily being 21 and a little
bit dumb and foolish we didn't listen to
any of that because well we found in
knocking on doors and talking to people
that my youth is what many people most
excited we had seven year old
grandmother's from the south side in the
north side saying that wow I like the
fact that you're young that gives me
hope for my grandchild my child we had
armies of young people knocking on doors
every Saturday and it's hard it's easy
to close the door in like a Jehovah's
Witness it's easy to close the door in
the cells man it's hard to close the
door in the 12 year old adorable kid who
say Michael Tubbs for City Council and
we found that seriously it works and and
we found that every single thing that
experts were telling us to do although
true for them were wrong in the special
case of this campaign arm also and
additionally experts also talked about
things like don't only talk to people
who vote but before we hire the campaign
consultant we had no idea what we were
doing so I said to win a race yet to
knock on doors and talk to people but I
didn't know there's any strategy to that
I thought you just picked the
neighborhood you knocked on every door
you talk to her if I hint that's how you
win so that's what we did but we started
with what I learned at the d.school to
be done as extreme users we started when
the poorest housing developments in the
city probably not with a lot of voters
and we spent two weeks it's knocking on
every door they're talking to them about
their hopes their aspirations and what
they wanted for the city but was in
talking to this extreme user group the
group that wasn't on our nation builder
files that won't show up on voter
registration rolls that we found our
campaign message it was really one about
moving the city for then that many
communities have felt bankrupt for a
long time that the seeds financial
bankruptcy was only a symptom of a
deeper bankruptcy and leadership in
rural bankruptcy in a bankruptcy of
vision and that's what we ran on so
everyone was talking about the fiscal
constraints and bankruptcy really
important topics but for voters they
want to talk about what's the vision for
Stockton people were talking about
entitlement reform and things of that
sort very important conversations but
the voice we talked to her like mr.
Tubbs we've been feeling banquet for a
long time
we go to bed listen the gunshots it's
violent it's it's it's not safe and and
it's so so funny because afterwards
would be got the experts in we stop
doing a lot of that outreach not a hard
work and talking to people who may not
vote because of resource constraints but
I humbly submit there's no way we would
have picked the message that resonated
with so many people and we had not
talked to the extreme users the people
who don't vote the people who aren't
going to donate because they really
helped define the message and run that
resonated citywide so I november six
2012 we actually won the election with
more votes than any other candidate
running for any City Council seat we won
with sixty-two percent of the vote and
the first time running and it was
craziness because of these lessons
really around so the valley experiences
being mounted one's really around expert
opinion be not so expert and then the
last lesson from the campaign is this
idea that those who are with you then
we'll be with you win our campaign was
ran by my best friends from college my
girlfriend my best friends from high
school and my family and that was the
core so often times when people didn't
show up when people didn't believe when
people didn't invest the time and energy
needed to run the campaign the people
that were with me back then when I was a
16 year old in south stockton just
trying to apply the college or when I
was at Stanford running crazy on the
basketball court to Arriaga or at a set
of Drake lounge parties in New Zealand
maybe maybe not okay but the people i
was with euge about partying with those
are the same people that helped power my
campaign in fact my best friend from
Stanford Cameron Henry he came up with
the idea of reinvent Stockton we were in
kimball we're sitting down I told him
Cameron I'm running for City Council he
said tubs I'm applying for med school
how can I help and then he end up
designing our websites designing our
flyers and coming up with this idea of
reinvent Stockton that's really been
resonating and still has a following and
a hashtag and really a movement around
it to this day and it was important I
think often times as we get older as we
think about scaling we forget about we
always want new canoe
shins and new people we need to connect
with this person or that person but my
experience has taught me that those
periphery relationships are important
but it's really those people that been
with me before the campaign before the
idea before anything people who are with
me just eating and talking who have
really been the base that really helped
me build my campaign so those are the
four lessons from the startup phase and
now I want to talk a little bit about
after you're elected after the fanfare
after all that how do you govern so so
in the ramp up and scale phase I think
there's also been three lessons um the
first lesson has been this idea of don't
despise small beginnings I'm not a
technical expert but from what I've read
and from the people i've talked to it
seems like everyone's obsessed with this
idea of scale like i have this small
idea how do i scale it 100 x times and
things like that and the politics is
almost the same way people get it one
office and they think about okay how do
i go from city council to un ambassador
or ha go from city council the UN
secretary-general it's crazy my wait
wait wait start with city council and in
the first lesson I've learned since
being in office is don't despise the
small beginnings or the startup phase
because those lessons I shared with you
are really the lessons I help govern the
decisions I make every single day it's
it's it's be have the door slammed in my
face and being chased by Chihuahuas and
rip no I know like dogs so I was very
traumatic so you guys are laughing but I
was trauma for me but it was those
experiences like that keep me humble
it's talking to the grandmother on the
porch or talking to the people who don't
vote who really informed it as soon as I
make and I think oftentimes we're always
in so much of a hurry to move on to the
next and get bigger and better when it's
really the basics and the small
beginnings that set the foundation for
any skill that comes on top of it I'm
the second lesson from governing or the
ramp up phase is this idea that you
don't know everything and that's okay
and that's really hard especially in
politics because for some reason people
think that you are a fusion of Jesus
Buddha Mohammed
um everybody and Tina Seelig John
Hennessy all the smart people in the
world in one body and you have the
answers to and tropical problems like
homelessness and water issues and
poverty and crime and you and you will
only have the answers and there's a lot
of pressure to feel like you're the
expert but I realize that you're not
knowing everything that's been so
freeing because open the door for me to
connect with people who do have the
answers so it's been great to work on
issues like poverty and realize that I
have some Stanford experience and lived
experience but there's some subject
matter experts who've been doing this
work in this community for 25 years who
may not have the degrees or the pedigree
but they know what they're talking about
and spending so free to say you guys you
know what I don't know I don't know I
know that someone knows so let's find
this answer collectively so don't feel
pressure to know all the answers or have
all the answers because part of my
opinion entrepreneurship and iteration
is not knowing with what you're doing is
going to work it's the iteration
experimentation that leads to knowledge
that knowledge is not already baked in
and then number two I realize that what
I don't know my users know that the
community knows the grandmothers who may
not speak English that will know whether
it would take for their kid to go to
school the unemployed people know what
skills they need the employers know what
skills unemploy need that all these
users around me have the answers to the
questions it's been so freeing to learn
that I don't have to know everything and
the only thing I need to know is how to
find answers and how to connect with
people and how to humble myself and open
myself so that other people are able to
bring their expertise to the table the
third lesson from sort of this ramp up
phase is the idea of having my personal
angel investors having people who
invested in me early on so a lot of my
big campaign donors we're actually
people I've met on this campus when i
was a freshman people i met at bill
development dinners or different events
and people like that who have been so so
helpful instrumental to this day that
finding early investors angel investors
people with some experience and
seasoning can help put your energy
and you to use and bring some experience
to it it's been so great because we
realize that what i like and experience
they make up and what they like an
energy eye makeup and it's the idea of
trying new things together collectively
I'm it's so humbling that every friday i
worked with a group of community leaders
who have been doing work in my district
4 30 40 50 years literally and we set
the table together and they tell me
their experience I tell them my ideas we
push back and forth and some messy
process but usually we come up with
really good community solutions but has
been very key about finding these early
on people who believe in angel investors
like a pusher product but in my case
that could help me push policy push
ideas push the system in the practice to
really improve outcomes and my community
and but i had to pivot a year ago in
terms of how I was approaching my work
as a council member i was reading
through some first graders about Martha
King around this time and we got to the
part where Martha King was assassinated
and I'm not a psychologist by training
so I was not equipped to prepare or
prepare to talk to a six-year-old about
death so I try skipped through the page
really quickly and then a kid stopped me
and said no mr. Tubbs my uncle was shot
and he said it so matter-of-factly I
thought his uncle had lived that's all
I'm so sorry to hear that I hope I'm
glad he's ok nice oh no he's dead and
there another kid raised his head says
my aunt got shot and I'm like okay well
I'm sorry and then before I could stop
almost every kid in that classroom had
known somebody that had been shot at six
years old and I like that the t-shirt
the teacher looked at me I'm not trying
to cry from these kids because they look
like everything stir like this just what
happened this reality teachers looking
at me I'm like it's your clouds but how
are we going to how are going to do this
but it was in that moment I realized
something because at Stanford I was
really big on social entrepreneurship I
was like we got an idea a program i got
or we can solve it so immediately my
mind with your programs it's like ok
these kids have a lot of trauma let's
put them in a nice mentorship program
several which I've star
my first year in the office almost like
maybe their parents may have records
let's put them in some back to work
programs i started and i was my mind was
running but then i realized that for
what they were going through programs
yes silly what work weren't enough that
the charity i was doing the social
entrepreneurship the program's the
filling in gaps was important work but
it wasn't really enough to drive the
change or make the impact i went to see
my community and then i was reminded not
just this all you have on the same day
it's like a couple couple months later
i'm thinking about this issue and i was
you might have a story my mom dad taught
me growing up about a man that was on a
road on his way somewhere like thousands
of years ago so he was under his on a
donkey or horse down this narrow road
the Jericho Road and he was robbed left
on the side of the road to die and then
like a politician came by and saw the
man on the side of the road and say you
know what this man chose to be on the
side of the road we don't when his kind
of our country anyway they're going to
bring guns and weapons of mass
destruction he deserves going to solve
the road that's his lot in life and then
I think my mom told me like a minister
came by but he was late for church so he
said you know what this mess on side of
the road i'ma pray for him but I'm have
to keep it moving and then maybe a
venture capitalist or a Stanford
entrepreneurship student saw the kid on
the side of the road and said that's an
interesting problem i'm gonna think of
an idea on my way to class but let me
put this in mind my iphone and come back
to it later but then finally a good
Samaritan saw this man on the side of
the road got off his high horse bound up
his wounds give him some money put them
in hotel and put them up and and that
mentality was what was driving a lot of
my service pursuits frankly I was like I
want to be that good samaritan for
stockton i want to get stopped but i'm
doing a 10 to the immediate need hope
people get well and on and on the way
but i recently just got back from a trip
to israel and i realized that the
Jericho Road is actually structured or
conducive for ambushing that the road is
very narrow and it makes it easy for
someone to get jumped in an ambush and
that cost me to really think about how
and all the social entrepreneurship
stuff I was doing the program
maturity how I was meeting immediate
needs but not getting out system-wide
solutions and I was I was beating the
need and hoping this one person but
there was thousands of kids in my city
50,000 people I represent 300,000 people
in the city as a whole who really did
the systemic solutions and that that
charity or the Good Samaritan impulse
would not be enough to move the needle
in Stockton so then our red mountains
beyond mountains by Paul Farmer an
excellent book and he had this idea of
structural violence and he talked about
how in some communities like Stockton in
other places in the world that that that
divides we see is actually structual
that individuals aren't necessarily the
cause for all the issues we see that
poor people aren't poor just because
they want to be poor and kids are not
doing well in schools is because I don't
want to do well in schools and prisons
are full of black and Latino men and
black and Latino women just because
these people are have a gene in them to
be criminal but there's actually been
structured in that way so I really
really reposition myself and spent the
last year and a half in stock and
thinking about how do I move from
charity to justice how do I move from
solving immediate needs as a
entrepreneur in government to really
solving system-wide challenges and the
short answer is that's so much work and
so much more difficult than putting the
kids in the mentorship program it's so
much work is so much more difficult than
throwing money on scholarships it's so
much work and so much more difficult
because it requires me not just to get
off my horse and help the one kid get
off the side of the road but to stay in
that role in figure out a way to
restructure it so it doesn't happen
again and that takes a lot of time and
energy so i'm going to spend just a
couple minutes talking about the
difference between charity and jess's
because whether you're in government or
not as a citizen in this country you
have a part to play and making sure that
we change the structures so that your
innovative solutions are able to scale
in a way that actually gets to real life
solutions so I think the difference
between charging and justice for me is
that charity is like it's like it's like
bandage right
it's band-aids it's painkillers and
justice is the surgery for example last
month my two of my wisdom teeth decided
to have a conversation on the freeway
and one was just on literally on a nerve
and jumping up and down the other one
was laughing and I was in so much
intense pain and my dentist gave me some
painkillers and some mouthwash and they
worked perfectly so I don't feel the
pain anymore but in two weeks I have to
have surgery because eventually the pain
is going to come back and I could keep
taking the painkillers and keep doing
the mouthwash and feel good in the
moment but next year 20 years from now
the wisdom teeth still have to be taken
out cuz I've done nothing to address the
root cause which is that I have too many
teeth in my big mouth and I think that's
the same way in terms of thinking about
charity and justice that charity is what
we do and it feels good and it's
important but justice is the hard work
of surgery of what it takes to move the
country for and and then I also think
that in terms of our old work that
charity is me throwing resources at an
issue and make the assumption that the
problem is one of resources if they had
more of this if they have more in that
if I give to them what I have then that
solves a problem but but but justice is
really about putting myself my brain my
resources my talent my time in my body
and on the line in a way until we really
get at a solution and that's not sexy
that's not easy that's incredibly
difficult but that's the only way we as
a society will progress in my humble
opinion and since I made that paradigm
shift I've seen some changes we move
from programs to really thinking through
collective impact strategies for self
stocked and we've realized that people
are sick because there's no access to
health clinics so now we're opening a
health clinic we realize that people
were in poverty because there's no word
for them the bank and save their money
that there was nothing but predatory
check cashing places that charge twenty
to twenty-five percent interest on
simple transaction so we said let's go
to bank there and we realize our schools
in their proof so we've been working on
organizing around schools and we realize
that the people we serve don't come in
silos they don't come they don't operate
in
also we can operate in silos that they
don't just need one thing that they need
jobs and housing and safe streets and
educate everything most you guys had
growing up as what people need and how
do we work collectively to do it it's
also been really humbling because it's
taught myself lots of the city that we
can't do this alone that takes the
nonprofit leaders the community
organizers the clergy the county the
school board and individual residents to
really really really get at these
justice based solution so I'm a little
bit not sad it's a little bit worrying
because the mission run in Stockton now
went from a four to eight year election
cycle to 20 30 years so i think i might
be in stockton for a while but i would
say it's so much more fulfilling to be
working towards something that doesn't
just get at an immediate itch or
immediate need it really gets that
intractable long-term systemic system
changes in solution it's ugly messy work
but so incredibly fulfilling because you
finally feel like you're doing something
so that you won't have to repeat it
again in 30 or 40 years but all that was
the introduction so what I really really
want to talk about what I really really
wanted to talk about was I've been
reading some articles about Silicon
Valley lately I'm sorry the essay I
think by Paul Graham that talked about
how inequality was just a byproduct of
progress and it's okay that society is
unequal that wealth inequalities at the
highest point it's been since the Gilded
Age because we're making advancements
and then I read this article about
what's wrong with Silicon Valley and I
was reading all these things that caused
myself to think about wow this is such a
great opportunity to talk to the future
of Silicon Valley because if I'm honest
my biggest fear is imma commit myself
and my Stanford education to fixing
these very difficult problems and
community and Stockton but that our
society won't progress with it I'm
worried that i will continue this
all my time and resources and energy
really thinking through how do we make
sure every kid korea at grade level in
third grade how do you make sure every
kid is in a high-quality preschool how
do we help parents learn the importance
of reading to their children how do you
make sure that police community
relationships are okay how do you make
sure everyone has access to fresh fruits
and groceries now to do all that great
work in Stockton while society continues
to get worse and worse I'm extremely
worried about my my kid acts to me one
day like why dad in a time with all
these technological advancements and all
this good stuff people freaking out how
to live on Mars and on the moon and you
guys are the black president but people
still had to go to the streets and tell
people that black lives matter I'm
worried I'm really frankly afraid about
what happens when we let prophet
determine policy and I think we've seen
some of that with the private prison
industry where literally private prison
corporations have helped write the
country's criminal justice policies for
the past 20 years I'm worried that that
will spend all our time and all our
energy and all our smart on on making
cool products but really forgetting
about people and I'm not really talking
about the people in this room because
the people in this room and most people
listening to podcasts they're going to
be a-okay you are going to be fine it
could be extreme inequality and you'll
be at the top so everything will be fine
for you and that seriously and that's
okay but worry about all the people I
represent or frankly ninety-nine percent
of the rest of the world so if I could
leave you with one challenge it would be
the carve up some space carve out some
time to use your entrepreneurial thought
and leadership and brilliance to really
solve some of these really intractable
problems I think it's crazy that we
create apps that scale 100 x times but
haven't yet figure out a way to educate
people not to be racist I think it's
ridiculous that we have all these apps
and we have space x and i'm going to get
my matching on the moon one day
hopefully it but and all that happens
but yeah we still have kids we have
another way to get kids to read that
greg level I I find it insulting that we
could figure out funding
streams and and new funding schemes and
raise capital all those things but we
can't figure out school district funding
policy in California that works for
everyone that we have the answers to
these other problems but the real
problems in terms of what type of
society we want to live in in terms of
weds it mean to be a moral nation what
does it mean to be a really great nation
as President Obama says that we're not
working on those issues with the same
gusto as work on others and that's not
to say be a poor councilman like me
because that's not going to risk either
but it is to say with your brains
knowledge talent skills and resources
there has to be a way that we could
redefine traditional Silicon Valley
terms there has to be a way we could
redefine what value is so that lives are
as valuable as projects I don't I don't
see anyone can live in the country where
twelve-year-old Tamir rice is murdered
playing in a park that that's crazy to
me III don't I'm confused as to how we
can allow ourselves to work on these
other issues and not pay enough
attention to the issues that will
determine the quality of life for our
kids and kids kids and kids kids kids we
have hundreds of millions of people on
snapchat and yet we still are people who
don't believe in climate change are
blocking our progress to change it that
we have all these great products made by
immigrants but yet we're saying keep
Syrian refugees out the country so I'm
asking you as I prepare to close now we
really need your help that the you guys
are so smart so brilliant so talented
and the same people that create google
facebook instagram sun microsystems
could help us think about how to make
sure there's no poverty in america for
example or how do we make sure that the
education system is equitable or how do
we make sure we at least provide an
equality of opportunity because I
refused I know people in Stockton who
are so smart and so talented I've met
people who can make ten dollars last two
weeks I can't do they compare over the
bridge with five dollars you know so at
me we've have all these great people
doing great things who don't yet have
the same opportunities and I don't have
the answers but I do think the answers
are in this room in this community and
on the podcast and
concert with the communities I represent
now so I prepare the clothes for
question answer my junior year in
college I went on the Freedom Rides with
original freedom writers and one extra
question I really motivates my work that
I went to leave with you all today well
true question is actually the first one
he said i was born in August fourth 1961
why was I day in put it and I said well
you were arrested and then he said well
on that day barack obama was born and
then he said i had no idea that the
choices I made that day as a 20 year old
college student with paved the way so
that 50 years later a kid who couldn't
get a cup of water at the counter will
one day be President and then he said
what are you prepared to do today it's
not 50 years later the world is a little
better so that's the first of two
questions I'm going to leave with us the
first is what are we prepared today in
addition to making profits and money and
products so that 50 years later
societies a little more equal so that 50
years later this room looks even more
like what the rest of the country looks
like what are we prepared to do that so
that 50 years later there's more
opportunity for children up and down the
income scale and throughout the country
and frankly the world and then the
second question really came from the
article what's wrong with Silicon Valley
and he said silicon valley is losing its
soul got in this mask commercialism
consumption and making billions of
dollars every other day that we're
losing some of the things that make us
human make us human medicine society and
it reminds me of a scripture that i read
this morning that said what does it
profit a man or a community or value to
getting the whole world have all the
resources all the talent all the
intellect but then lose lose its soul
and with that i'll say thank you time
for Q&A
oh how questions oh okay you are now
running for mayor how different is it
now running your campaign how different
is it then your first campaign it it
fake it poses new challenges um because
when I was running at first it was cool
to be 21 years old and do things that
weren't clinical professional or kind of
quirky or not if so he's young he's cute
but now I'm like an old politicians been
for years I've been the office for four
years so now there's a bit much higher
expectation to kind of dot the i's cross
the t's and also it's easy to run when
you have no record could you just say
what you're going to do but now you have
to go before the public and say for
three years you've entrusted me with
your votes with your support and this is
what I've been able to accomplish and
for some people that's enough for some
people to like what you could do this
this this is this so it's it's a little
bit more challenging now you have a
record to run on and you've had to tell
some people know and sell some people we
can't do this right now until some
people whoa this is a great idea but we
don't have the resources yet because we
just exited bankruptcy and that makes
people not like before everyone used to
like me and now like only half the
people I used to like me like me so I
look a little more difficult hey how's
it going I'm good man how are you so
when I first looked at it whole series
yeah I look through the street vision
and your name just turn right now it's
like entrepreneurial leaders that was
the earring in my ear I know then the
pitcher yeah the City Council like just
you know and to the extent that I have
knowledge on whole political system is
from watching the wire and so my
question is this how do you keep
yourself from you know being into the
system and then you know keeping being
part of this spiraling political system
that Obama alluded to yesterday you know
I like what what are the expectations
for yourself as usual I'm working with
Google
oh yeah so the question was i watch the
wire how do you keep yourself from being
like the politicians on the wire
essentially right how do you keep
yourself inoculated no seriously it was
how you keep yourself inoculated from
crazy political stuff like not being
part of the system but hoping to change
I'll reform the system yeah well
actually I'm working with Google X now
in a suit and it's a joe you could have
laughs no I it's a good question so the
thing is the thing about politics is
that it is dirty that sometimes you have
to like knuckle up and fight that
sometimes you have to make alliances and
sometimes you have to compromise i saw
the system work so i think for me I
trinocular myself by being very true to
the values i uphold so when something
comes across the desk or for a vote I
always think okay is this fair is it
equitable does it help the city like
really basin really basic tests like
it's going to harm people is this
corrupt is this evil and that helps
keeps me inoculate cuz some people don't
have that moral compass frankly so that
helps it also i think oftentimes people
forget that before they elected their a
citizen like you're not there's nothing
special about you i don't have special
councilman blood like i'm a regular
person who is elected but oftentimes
when you're elected you're in meetings
all the time with the elected officials
and you go to events with elected
officials and if you don't go to
eventual elected officials if you're in
the house they say the councilman is
here you stand up a tear when crops for
you and that becomes it becomes like a
normal you think that's who you are that
you're the councilman so i have to
remind myself that no my name is michael
and if i lose tomorrow if i decide to do
something else that's fine because i
care about these issues and right now
politics is a way to address those
issues but 10 years from now and it
might be something else and be very open
to that and i spent a lot of time with
kids because kids don't care if your
socks bit smashed they'll tell you if
your wrinkles they'll tell you they're
great so i spent a lot of time in
classrooms and with younger people to
help kind of keep me focused on the
issues
hi how do you think we can encourage
social entrepreneurship when that
involves taking risks and all the expert
advice is to minimize risk so that you
can get reelected yeah man that's the
act that's an excellent question so the
question was how can we encourage social
entrepreneurship and government when
it's about taking risks but you want to
minimize risks so you could get
reelected that's interesting incentive
system oh and I don't know if there is
like a real straight answer for that but
to the best of my knowledge I think in
terms of how how I think of it it's
really around sort of what am I willing
to take a risk for like some things I'm
not going to take a risk on like I'm i
would take a risk around helping
ex-felons get jobs because that's
important to me I might not take as big
a risk for some other issue that's not
as core essential to me and I think
that's how I do it so if I take a loss
for this risk I'm ok with it because I
know this is the issue I'm passionate
about I care about it's good for the
community I think in part of it is also
i think it has to be just a more
infusion of that into government because
government is always access the city
manager at the time I why is government
afraid of risk and part of its cuz
government stole anything that's really
at scale that touches everybody for even
more importantly the most vulnerable
rely on government the most right so I
can have this cool idea for water
delivery but if it doesn't work that
people are going to feel the most are
like the most destitute the most poor
the people I need the service is the
most that makes it a little bit harder
to take risks so you can't so what I
tell my colleagues on councils like
let's take smart risks in a way that
don't that doesn't that won't unduly
harm the most vulnerable but still allow
us to innovate and kind of become better
at service delivery did I answer your
question ok yeah you talked a bit of a
student justice and fighting long-term
sessions of things like
salvaging the bank or I mean check out
the making a help surface on you you've
been talking it more about like how you
identified those things as real needs
yeah um so right because the timer was
like super on me so I'll try to make
sure I was good part of it was that we
established like a coalition of
organizations in the district who had
similar interests around we want to see
this dish it get better and then we did
this huge needs assessment over the
summer knocked on 800 doors it came up
with a community needs assessment and
the priorities were healthcare facility
bank and recreation activity for kids
and education and safety so we got the
priorities from the community and then
it was like okay these are their
priorities what can we do to address
these concerns and it was like okay well
how do you get a bank here well let's
talk to the bank president figure out
what his interests are will it make him
for the bank there and then for the
health predict we found that one of our
partners had a health clinic that was
dormant like literally a health clinic
that was dormant for like seven years
and people saying anyhow it's crazy if
he were sent any health care there's
like okay well why is the health clinic
not open oh no one really had an answer
which was fresh ready but it was easy to
the solution you know we don't have
anyone to run it so let's talk to the
local community medical clinics facility
and then so things like that is really
finding needs but then also filling in
the gaps what kind of resources are
already in the community are you talking
a little bit some of the problems that
you see in society such as mass
incarceration or climate change I do you
think that other than the fact that
maybe like you kind of a little bit
where is the next generation of Stanford
students need to help tackle these
problems do you think that there are
other reasons other than maybe that our
best and brightest might not be working
on these problems that could be
perpetuating their existence yeah this a
variety that's an excellent question so
the question was for a lot of issues
besides the fact that oftentimes the
quote-unquote best and brightest are
working on those issues where are some
of the other causes for these things to
happen I mean a lot of it and my opinion
is also profit driven so if I'm making a
lot of money by polluting and
politicians need money to run for office
I'm going to donate to people who won't
make me stop polluting
and it's more complicated with that but
I think for a lot of things whether it's
mass incarceration climate change
immigration almost every big issue
there's some underlying profit motive
does driving without a call ah
positioning that's antithetical to
progress and some people may dispute the
science although like that the president
said 200 nations majority of scientists
don't so what have you learned about
leadership that's my hot dog now I mean
like you know what your personal skills
what skills have you gained over this
time what skills have I gained over this
time it was a point I I've written down
by forgot it but I really i learned that
consensus building is often times more
bear more better it's oftentimes buried
in competition yeah I think off the time
especially in politics you want to be
like the man and get the credit by learn
to really make progress and get things
done that's really about bringing a
coalition of folks together it's really
consensus building and I didn't realize
that was a skill until i looked back at
like even the things like that stanford
from starting nonprofits to living
student groups all of it was finding
people who are smarter than me and like
okay can you help do this and why don't
you do this and not do this and really
working in teams and partnerships so
that's been a skill i think the other
skill has been really around empathy and
listening the Nanyan realized i was a
skillet i did the d.school fellowship
and then we're doing empathy interviews
yeah and also I'm pretty good that's
what I do I listen to people I hear
they're nice i come over the solution
i'm good at this empathy stuff so that
that's been his skill and then also i
realize that i'm i'm better essaying
known i thought i was that if the data
is very clear like we don't have money
we don't have money no and I'm really
good at being the bad guy and I didn't
think I had it in me I'm probably to get
it now I'm like no there's no resources
that's fit but that's a no let's put all
the way one day but today no decision
you have to make what's the most
difficult decision I've had to make it's
a recent one so there's a part of the
city that's next to mine it's the east
inside of Stockton and there was a
library that was open there that was
shut down as part of the bankruptcy and
people are calling for the library to be
open I mean to open the library building
is libraries cost money about half the
million dollars a year to operate on an
ongoing basis and a big part of
Stockton's bankruptcy was that
oftentimes we made knee-jerk decisions
about okay this feels good let's put
this arena in we need an arena let's do
this and without really thinking about
how do you pay for it after the first
five years playing over the next 30
years how do you pay for this library so
there's no law keeping the advocates say
when you dis library open you care about
literacy you care about this you care
about this therefore you should open the
library and it's been difficult because
I'm like yeah a library would be good
but in that part of town given the
resources we have in Stockton it would
also be good to have employment services
it'll also be good to have health care
services it will also be good to have
Wi-Fi internet so while we find a
solution that combines the best of all
these but and there's some people are
like no we want a library so it's been
really instead also an election year or
libraries no one hates libraries like
everyone likes libraries right so it's
kind of dumb to be arguing about no we
can open the library because the easier
political decision to be like just open
the library but we someone found like a
funding stream for yet and if we do find
a funding stream those several city
needs at least need consideration for
that fun those funds like our
homelessness problem is has increased
over the past couple years I'm just
infrastructure needs justice all these
other needs in addition to a library so
it's been difficult because I'm like
soup like these people they're loud the
communities English language learners
like a library be such a benefit so
that's been a tough decision a debate
we're still having you talk to you I
like the importance of the people that
you surround yourself with up in your
what political career I'm great
attention okay okay I was curious now
that the decisions that you make out our
greater consequences how do you make
decisions about who listen to who to
keep close to the distance yourself
problem yeah that's a good question so
how do you make decisions as to who to
listen to
so first I think before you listen to
anybody you have to have just in my head
just like I called non-negotiables or
non-starters so if it hurts people if
it's not fair if it's not going to work
I can support it and then on certain
issues I try to find people who aren't
connected to the issue personally who
don't have a financial interest or
political interest who are just
concerned and I listen to them and
they're not listening to people who have
like political interest I just as
important to them or they have a
financial interest I listen to them and
then I listen to staff and I put all
that together in a secret sauce and by
the time is time to vote i have an
answer usually it works because you here
because it's interesting that people see
the world really different based on
their position so if there's something
coming up now I'm going to financially
benefit from that needs to happen now
and that's one perspective but for
someone who may have not got the big or
it doesn't qualify they have a
difference for prospective and by
putting all their perspectives together
with some data and some like common
sense you're able to my opinion fine I
think obvious things that make are good
and I think most people would agree but
of course you can't please everybody
personal decisions ah like what career
choice in career choice away oh I suffer
for career choice so sometimes I ask for
help after I made a decision just so
people feel involved in the decision in
terms of personal stuff they work
because people wouldn't know so that's
part of it I think up like I'll pray but
sup but most the time I kind of know
what I want to do and I think oftentimes
we're taught not to trust our gut and
intuition and I agree that shouldn't be
the sole basis upon which you make
decisions but there's something
viscerally there that's important to
listen to it in my experience so that's
kind that's what made me run for mayor I
was going to run for county supervisor
but then something just did not sit
right and I was at home let me
investigate this and then I thought
about all the great things America do
not
I'm okay the stuff we're doing the south
stockton we can scale to the whole city
I'm a run for mayor and everybody don't
run for me that's crazy and I was like
you had tubs from it but it so it's at
things that make sure of listening to
people you trust but also just really
listen to your gut because it usually
has if not the right answer in answer so
you talked about on your first campaign
a lot of people who r ich melde in that
process we're like when you're best
friends you're over your family now that
you're in another campaign is it kind of
those same people by your side involved
as like to the same extent it's a great
question i hope they're listening
because ever since i've been elected not
all of them honesty she's still helpful
but everyone a lot of people are like
because other people have lives too so
they're not as invested so so that's it
I'm just talking to Cameron about this I
main camera remember I used to call you
every day and on this mayoral campaign I
hardly even reach out to you because
you're a med school and he's still very
very hopeful but it's been a new cast of
characters in a way but also the past
few years has really been around
building institutions so it's not so
dependent on individuals that I'm not
depending on one person to do all my
data needs you know one person to do all
my mail that I have built institutions
and supporters so that my family doesn't
have to walk every single week and then
deal with me every single day and all
that stuff that could just deal with me
and then other people can help with the
work part so it the cast of characters
I've changed for sure it's a good
question I was probably my favorite too
say you have a great idea or quality
that you wanna girl and one of their
colleagues is you know you're you know
it's a great idea you're one hundred
percent sure but one of your colleagues
we disagree with you and they're being
very simple what's your approach no
that's life okay so how do i do my job
every day is the question I'm joke and
I've great colleagues from the most part
um so the thing is you don't need seven
votes to get anything done you'll need
for so I just trying to count to four
and Lily that's why I do like as long as
I get the majority with me and then but
sometimes if the person who's against it
could be helpful or as persuasive or has
like influence on the issue I try at
least be with them to hear their
concerns even though we may disagree I
at least want to see if I can address
their concerns because maybe they see
something i don't see i'm spike why are
you against this what wait is it and
sometimes you get the truth sometimes
you get other stuff that's not quite the
truth but it's instructive tells you how
you kind of shape the message around it
so it gets done that's your question
yeah yeah alright what were the lessons
from your time in Stanford undergrad
translate into your work is a social
option I think by what were the lessons
from Stanford of the most transferable
staff has a really special place i call
it disneyland in the way don't think
about your in this bubble you have like
the smartest professors in the world you
have the smartest group of 18 to 30 year
olds in the world and you have unlimited
resources so it's just a place of great
exploration iteration and yes yes yes so
stop tins a little bit different in some
respects but but i think the lesson I
learned in terms of thinking big and not
being afraid to try and go has been
helpful I think the lessons around just
relationship building that one of my
best friends now who's been very helpful
politically with someone I was on long
street with in cape town for three
months being overseas and we just really
hit it off a bit and and things like
that is the opponents of the people you
meet in the dish and in your dorm and
or in some way going to do something big
whenever they choose to do so having a
relationship a connection with them is
so helpful whether you're in social
entrepreneurship are just in life
because just having access to smart
people as a commodity please join me in
thanking Michael Todd
you